Here we go
Welcome everybody Jason Rosen here once again with Kevin Connors
Just crank out another webinar. We just want to do something really really simple, but something we both feel that is really super important and that's
Just cover basically enzymes
101 right Dr. C
Yes, sir what's that?
What I want
Absolutely super important
There's like I said, I think we talked about it one of the got video ones that
You know if there's one thing you can give the person start with
enzymes, so
Yeah, due to functional medicine. This is a new place to start. So yeah, this is just like a great place to start if you're just like
I just want to start doing something other than straight chiropractic. I mean this right here like like you said is just
great place to
If you're old the functional medicine, then this is a great place to start
That is an awesome point
Okay, all right. So first one
Hydrochloric acid so like it starts with the stomach no doubt about it. So
I think like most people understand this, but I think that probably there's a lot more that
Actually don't that understand how the you know the body works when it breaks food down. So
You know the body um start to chew it on some foods some enzymes get released
We turn the this food into a kind substance and then
The most important step that happens next is a hydrochloric acid needs to get squirted onto this food
And what does that do? It like probably number one not only does it help break the food down
But it helps disinfect the food and with the state of our food supply today
Holy cow to people have like tons of
Who knows what in the food supply and absolutely?
Another big piece of hydrochloric acid like in the big methylation craze is
You know, it's a huge huge methyl later. It's um it's chemical name is tri
You know methyl glycine. So you know this
Little simple simple little supplement, which I'm telling you like almost nobody in the country has enough of
Because the more protein you eat the more you know hydrochloric acid your body is going to get demand the more food you eat the more
hydrochloric acid
Your body is going to demand and your body will even release it when you come into contact with you know
Infections it'll use it to disinfect your organs. So it is so precious yet
It is in such short supply and just about anybody especially when they start to get into their mid-30s and beyond and
In my mind well especially with the the medication that's used today that affects
Our hydrochloric acid production of the deficiency and B vitamins that affects our hydrochloric acid production. Yep, absolutely. So um
Yeah, what else can we really say about HCl? I mean
It's absolutely critical and I believe that it's probably one of the number one reasons why people get ill in
The world is because they don't have enough of this stuff
Well, and it's it's the hard part for patients to understand it's counter intuitive because they think oh, I'm
Have this um acid bell Cheat up this acid. I have this
Reflux this gird so I need to take it into acid. Well, it does help the symptoms
It will take away that gird pain, but the reason why you have that
Gird pain is not because you have an excess
HCl it's because you have a deficiency in HCl
So you have to explain to your patients that the reason why you have that
That uh belchied up of acid is because you don't have enough of it to
Digest that bolus of food city to the stomach so that bolus is sitting in the stomach much longer than it's supposed to yep
Then the little acid you do have is
Bubblyed up to the top of the stomach you probably have a high it'll hurt. Yes
So it bubbles into the other side of the diaphragm
It squirts up into the esophagus and gives you all this pain. Yep, and yes, that is dangerous to the esophagus
But you got to fix the problem you actually actually give the person more HCl
Yep, so the number one symptom of need for hydrochoric acid is
acid reflux
That's right that's it and so you have to educate your patients about a little bit of anatomy and physiology
Yeah, a lot of people this they have a hard time getting their head around it and that's especially when
Everyone's pop and tums and role aids. They just they really have no idea of what they're doing
To themselves and you know blocking one of their most
Like one of the first lines of defense that you're given by God and your body and that's you know your your stomach acid
so
Yeah, other like um other symptoms of need um with HCl is definitely um
If you have you know b vitamin, you know problems
What do you agree? Yep. Oh
Absolutely as you touched out maybe one of the more important ones is that um
It's your first lighted offense against parasites. Yes
So um another symptom of need well and also prevention of need is you know
Like you said H. Pylori H. Pylori is a huge chronic problem leads to heart disease and just the host of other issues
And you know why do you get that in the first place? Well nine times that is 10 it's
lack of HCl and then other chronic problems like um, you know parasites people think they have you know ibs and
You know all these Crohn's and stuff like that they they don't know where it came from
Well it probably came because you didn't have enough hydrochoric acid to disinfect some food you ate
One day
And well you said it it's because it could be the cause of diet out of 10
Diseases no to aid right here. Yeah, so yeah if you're young um, I would say if you're really young um
And you're really athletic make sure you consume a good amount of really clean salt because you need the chloride fraction of that salt to make your own HCl
Especially if you live in a warm climate and then if you really want to keep yourself
Um, you know free from a lot of big big chronic problems
Yeah, I would say it's it's a it's your best bet to start
supplementing HCl probably when you what would you say about age 35 or so?
Oh, yeah, well these days it's even before that because you know
The typical America diet where people are eating all this junk food and stuff that's
Their HCl production even as a young child so that is true
Um, I mean I dose just personally I know some people
This just start with just taking one with every meal. It's just
You just have to even if they don't I don't it's not based upon symptoms even
They came into your office. They're not well
Even if you're practicing, you know straight chiropractic type practice where they're coming in with the headache
They're not well
so
Really every one of your patients should be on this product and I don't make a pity off of selling this product
So
Every person in your office should be making
Yeah, we should do something about that
But uh everybody should be out HCl. It just is just a given you
Yeah, I can't agree more it's my it's like people always ask me if I could only take one thing what would I take or what's your favorite multivitamin
I'm like HCl there's no way I would choose anything well because that's what's gonna cause you to get your nutrients out of your food
Right if you can't properly break it down you can't absorb it and
Then you you know, you're not gonna be getting the proper nutrients value of your food
I agree and what good is that if I'm gonna get exposed to some type of infection and then
You know, who knows what kind of problem some you know that could lead to so anyway
We could go on and on and on about this, but
We're talking about HCl though. Yeah, right
All right, well, please do I mean I love you too much. All right, so um, okay, so that's hydrochloric acid this product's got
HCl in it and some enzymes so it's a nice, you know kind of perfect place for someone to start
Up something to mention though when you take HCl
You do want to make sure you drink a good amount of water with it
Because it could create a little bit of a a burning sensation or it might take there might be an adjustment period
And usually that goes right goes away when you just drink enough water
So just don't take this on an empty stomach without water
And the best time to take it is usually middle or end of the meal
Go okay. All right, so
All right, so now we've got the food broken down and we've got it nice and disinfected the HCl is doing its job
Then the next thing we got to do is get into the small intestine and further break this stuff down. So
You know, let's talk about digestive enzymes and you know, just how important these guys are how deficient they are in today's society
okay
So well the HCl
Zine does have some digestive enzymes in it like you said
But when a person has more digestive problems, so the HCl's I by itself is just for everybody
Um, but when then now you have a patient that is having some digestive issues or you think that they have some leaky gut issues
Which everybody does right but you're treating them for those things
If you're getting into functional medicine enzymes like you said are step number one
You could cure half your patient's problems which is helping their gut here. So
doing
Digestimes is step number two
Yep for me. I don't put everybody on both HCl and
Digestimes or any other enzyme
But um
You know most of my patients do but I wouldn't put every single patient that walks at an average car practic door on both of these
but um certainly
When you're going to start dealing with their digestive issues you got to add more digestive
um
pancreatic digestive enzymes that are going to be in
working more of the small larger intestine. Yeah
and
Like a lot of people like again, ask, well, what do you take for you know like liver help and stuff like that
I'm like you got to start with the digestion first and the reason you probably have a liver problem to begin with
Is because you are not producing enough digestive enzymes to break your food down
And your body's backup system for that is to send rotting
You know food that's sitting in your intestine that you can't break down through the hepato portal system into the liver
So you know, everyone wants to oh, I want to do a liver detox
Well, why don't you start you know breaking your food down first
And then you know maybe start to work on the liver. So that's another you know
I think big point that a lot of people miss like you said you have to look at the anatomy of the body
And then of course people say oh my body produces enzymes. Why do I need more? Well, let's look at that
There used to be a ton more in our food supply
That was do you think a lot of people are out there or you know
Consuming fermented foods eating mostly fruit and vegetables and a little bit of protein
No, it's the opposite. They're consuming tons of carbohydrates and sugar and all these things that deplete enzymes
And they're not eating food that has enzymes in it. So
For your body to have to just make that sacrifice every single time you eat a meal because you're not eating properly
You definitely is you should look at supporting the body with additional enzymes
There's a cool like law called the adaptive law of secretion where your body will not
produce an extra enzyme if it doesn't absolutely have to
And so that that's something I relate to a lot of people and they say oh well
I don't want to take too many enzymes my body will stop making them on that's you know just definitely not
Yeah, that is not your enzymes you're not working on a negative feedback loop right
There's some interesting interesting study. I can recall where I saw it
So what are the journals about?
They did
Related to the size of americans pancreases over the last 60 years
And they equated it with the increased rate of pancreatic cancer
Oh wow and the hypothesis was that because the American diet has gotten so poor
The need for pancreatic enzymes has risen so people's pancreases have hypertrophied over time
And the stress on the pancreas is increased the rate of pancreatic cancer
Makes sense. It's sad. It's really really sad, but it
Unfortunately, it makes a lot of sense great great point doctor C
All right, so you can take a whole lot of stress off of it
Yes, you can take so much stress off of it just by um, you know
Take taking these guys or if you just want to go hardcore and you don't have like um histamine problems
You should be doing some fermented stuff or whatever
So anyway, we don't want to get too far down the road
So symptoms okay, the symptom list here could just go on forever
But the basic ones of course your gas and bloating your swollen hands and fingers, you know
You're wetting ring when you eat bad won't come off you know aches pains um, you know plaque on your teeth
I mean any other big ones that come to mind
Well, just any of your digestive symptoms which everybody has I mean you people are
Well, they want to run the labs to see if there's got inflammation
And there's leaky got issues and run the labs to see if there's
There's food sensitivities and when we talked about those and got one oh two oh one that they're so important to do
But you really want to start with just giving just giving these because
Really seriously you can help clear up a lot of their problems
By doing that so if they could break down
The the glee added into its amino acid component
Though you're not going to react to that right
So protein, nothing amino acid. Yeah, you're actually the the protein of the peptides
Of uh and not the individual libido acids. So uh proper digestion
You know, we forget just one oh one here of physiology you need HCl and enzymes to break food down
Otherwise, it's it's stayed in a log or peptide form if it's a protein
uh and
It it it's has more ability for your immune system to react to it
furthered out of the intestinal track. So
Yeah
So it's just you got to go with enzymes first
Yep, and I completely agree and another thing I like about this formula is it's really broad spectrum
It contains astrozyme which is actually been clinically proven to even further boost how quickly enzymes break down your food into
You know into amino acid which is
Well, the digestimes plus that I like so much is that it's just there's just not another enzyme on the market
That has the variety of enzymes in it that this does right
And then that is true
All right, well, thank you so much docs. That's enzymes 101 Jason Rosen here once again for dr. Kevin Connors
We hope you're getting a lot out of these and um, we hope to see you next time. Dr. Seast
All right. All right. Thanks so much. See you next time. Bye. Have a great day. Bye. Bye